and son it's absolutely lovely to see
here at collects menu today I believe
it's the first time to the convention it
is and I hope I'll be asked again
because it's quite fun
of course fans have been seeing you on
Game of Thrones again this season
haven't they tell me what it was like
joining that Game of Thrones world
well because I'm quite a peripheral
character and because I never know
what's going on either prior to my
appearance or after I'm always having to
find out what's going to happen to me
and inevitably there's somebody who's
read all the books and they say oh what
you playing I say kibe ah well you know
what's gonna happen to know tell me
what's good but I actually I don't mind
being out of the loop it's quite
refreshing not to you know to just dip
in and they're all lovely people and
then I go away again but this year I've
been honest back and I think I've got a
bit more to do I've got five episodes in
the next series but again you know what
I'm gonna be doing I have no idea
probably something very nasty she had to
filming with Jamie weren't you you're
filming fitting hit is called a hand for
example yeah I become an expert
prosthetic hand fitter person I can tell
you all about that my little bits in the
last series which are airing at the
moment I only had two scenes one was to
do the hand the other one I can't say
because it's not been out yet but it's a
more interesting scene and it gives you
a clue to what his journey might go into
I have things to do with the mountain
that's all I'm saying
it's on the edge of our seats now now
what was it like filming with Nikolai as
well he plays Jamie and of course in
that scene with the hand you also with
Cersei Lena Headey Anya yeah they're
lovely really lovely actors and their
maybe very welcome
because it can be a bit intimidating if
you're not involved and you're not part
of the big family and you just you feel
a little bit Oh am I gonna be good
enough you know what they need and
you're looking for that affirmation and
of course they're there they're just
actors like you and they know that
however old you get it doesn't get any
easier you're always thinking this is
where I get found out this is where they
decide he was okay but we don't need him
anymore
so um yeah they're lovely making you
feel very comfortable and relaxed
welcome she mentioned the mountain as
well we've got a new mountain this
season what was it like filming with him
and while he was prone and unconscious
so I think I'd probably said one word
Tim when he got up from the table after
about three hours and he was slightly
dazed and iced he I was introduced mrs.
Anton the guy but he's huge we got into
a minivan at one point and there was
room for him and not very many other
people did probably me because I'm tiny
and your character he is been called a
deplorable man by mysel he's played of
course by brilliantly by Julia clever
what do you think of pycelle hotel um
well I know Julian of old we were at the
RSC together years and years ago he's a
lovely man than a great actor I don't
I mean he's character as far as from the
perspective of Qyburn pycelle he's on
the way out
old school
and not radical enough in his approach
to finding out about how humans operate
and how they heal and how they're
injured and what's the best I mean I'm a
kind of an anarchic kind of medicine man
really who has very unorthodox ways of
approaching medicine and healing and
isn't averse to some very unpleasant
practices which he'd get struck off the
BMA like that wouldn't have a chance you
wouldn't want to go and see him with a
nasty spot because he'd probably take
your arm off he's it's had experiments
also we say a little bit experimental a
little bit yeah complete liability right
but then again that miss make of a lot
of fun to play over it's beginning to be
I mean you know I've just sort of dipped
in I've had like a scene here in her
series insects serious couple last year
but I've got five days on it on this one
five episodes so who knows what he's
going to get up to I certainly don't
because I'm not a script yet would you
like to based on what you've done so far
what do you like to see him get up to
what well I'd love to see him get up to
is some devilish activity outside of his
laboratory so that I could go back to
Dubrovnik which I thought was beautiful
but I got the feeling I will be in
Belfast for the next int I'm very
grateful for the work and I yeah I'd
love to go back to do probably so I I'd
love him to write something where he he
needs to be in the open air in a very
warm country for some very strange
reason why we don't know but you
it's important somebody's gonna do it
you be that man for that job now what do
you think the quality that you need to
survive in this very harsh world of Game
of Thrones are you need to be needed by
whoever's in power that's basically it
because the minute you're not necessary
you admit you're expendable
somebody's going to find you expendable
so at the moment he's doing a cake
because he's carving out a little niche
of have been needed he's replacing
pycelle as the go-to man for unorthodox
treatment and making people come back to
life he's getting a little bit of a
reputation for that so he's somebody to
cultivate rather than to get rid of long
wait lost I haven't read the book so I
don't know what happens to of course
Pocomoke george RR martin said there
might be a possibility of a game of
thrones movie what do you think of that
it's what would you like to see happen
in that I think it should be the movie
should be about Qyburn and then you know
with some other people yes came in
throws people thrown in because we like
to see them but basically should be
about him okay burn the movie and then
Qyburn to return of Qyburn now very
finally what was your reaction when you
saw that Joffrey death that actor was so
good at being so obnoxious
I think yeah a lot of people are very
glad to see the back of it not the actor
but that character he was so utterly
horrific it was it's like a Caligula
yeah
so I was cheering
you